hi guys and girls obviously welcome to
step number four of how to read to learn
foreign languages now I'm going to give
you a very quick tip about the so called
space-time repetition whenever you start
a new session you new reading session
and make sure that you go back to the
preceding session so to the twenty or
thirty pages or ten pages for that
matter that you've read before and you
read the sentences in which the words
that you didn't know are embedded so you
are going to review to do a quick review
just of the sentences in which you found
the words that you did know it's it's a
really efficient way to keep going to
remember that we never remember there's
a very high chance if you see a word
just once you're going to forget it so
make sure that you review the session
before starting the new one and for that
matter you could even do it after but my
my suggestion is to do it before just
always get rid of the things that are a
little bit less comfort comfortable if
you're not used to doing them and one
more thing is the fact that you always
have to remember that you when you mark
words make sure that you mark when I
what I mean by word is an expression
collocation you just don't think in
terms of single words and whenever you
for example marker words make sure that
you kind of create some context to it
now for example here in this book I have
this book is in Russian I found a word
like pretty manyanya and I made sure
when I when I jotted it down to also
arrive for example but I mean you could
in application to so I just in the same
here for aburana which is defense for
example your judge about all is to hold
the defense so I always make sure to add
some other elements to it to make it
more complete because words are like
fish in the sea they do just one one
fish is not enough you have you need a
solid fish to make it to make it
efficient so don't think about just in
terms of words but think in terms of
networks every time you find a word
when you add something to it thank you
for watching I'll see you at an episode
and number five